[Música]
Bienvenidos a Expreso de oriente El
magacín quincenal de France 24 en el que
les acercamos las historias de medio
oriente a América Latina Esto es lo que
veremos en el programa de hoy
iniciamos en Israel con la vuelta del
experiment ministro Benjamin netanyahu
al poder tras los comicios que tienen un
vencedor el partido de extrema derecha
poder judío que se ha convertido en la
tercera fuerza del país y es clave para
la formación de gobierno en Irán más de
un mes después de la muerte de la joven
maxa mini tras ser detenida por la
policía de la moral continúan las
protestas en varias ciudades del país a
medida que aumenta la brutalidad de las
fuerzas de seguridad iraníes y en Egipto
es la sede de la Cumbre mundial del
clima lakov 27 El delta del Nilo sufre
las consecuencias de la crisis climática
siendo una de las regiones del mundo más
sensibles a las altas temperaturas
iniciamos en Israel 16 meses después de
su salida Benjamin netanyahu regresa al
gobierno tras las Quintas elecciones en
menos de cuatro años Israel Podría tener
la inclusión de la extrema derecha su
ejecutivo más radical en una década y
nuestro corresponsal en Jerusalén
Federico cueva Barberena nos analiza
este panorama político
Israel se debatía entre civil sí o no y
finalmente ha sido así Benjamin
netaniagus regresa al poder solo 16
meses después de su salida y pese a
cargar con tres causas abiertas por
corrupción el dirigente de 73 años
prepara su vuelta al cargo de Primer
Ministro para un tercer mandato algo
inédito en la historia israelí baby
llega impulsado por el ascenso del
extrema derecha representado en sionismo
religioso de discurso antiárabe homófobo
Ultra religioso y nacionalista que en
los últimos años pasó de marginal a ser
la tercera fuerza en la próxima quenese
su cara más conocida es el legislador y
tamar bengivir un político hijo de
inmigrantes iraquíes laicos Pero formado
políticamente en el kahanismo una
ideología que pregona en supremacismo
judío y el Ultra nacionalismo el mismo
es el residente de un asentamiento en
nebrón defiende la anexión total de los
territorios palestinos ocupados y entre
otras cosas ha propuesto deportar
aquellos que no sean leales a Israel y
hasta una reforma judicial para limitar
a la Corte Suprema así de estas
legislativas se desprende la
normalización de estos sectores más
radicales de la derecha israelí y la
caída de la izquierda que fue de fuerzas
fundacional del Estado El ejemplo es el
partido merece que no estará en el
parlamento por primera vez en desde su
creación en 1992 era una de las pocas
fuerzas sionistas en la quenet que
defendía los diálogos de paz con los
palestinos y criticaba la ocupación
israelí además de la representación
femenina entre los parlamentarios de la
futura coalición cae a un 15% a la luz
de que los dos partidos Ultra ortodoxos
no permiten a mujeres en sus listas la
otra pérdida es para la representación
árabe que se fragmentó en tres partidos
separa las elecciones y son los dos
lograron cruzar el umbral con este
panorama Aunque entre la población
Palestina no había expectativas de
mejoras con ningún gobierno israelí el
futuro ejecutivo más radical de
netaniaco amenaza con profundizar aún
más las restricciones en las vidas de
los palestinos y recrudecer la violencia
en los territorios ocupados
y seguimos en Israel porque como
decíamos la entrada de la ultraderecha
liderada por bengivird un político
abiertamente xenófobo y racista el
supremacista religioso podría eliminar
cualquier apariencia de autonomía
Palestina para analizar esto tenemos con
nosotros a Inés abet rasen ella es
directora de incidencia del palestein
institute diplomas y gracias por estar
en Flash 24 Inés lo primero que se
espera de este parlamento que es el más
radical en la última década y que supone
esto para la población Palestina
sí Bueno de hecho no es la primera vez
que la extrema derecha está en el
parlamento israelí y los palestinos yo
puedo hablar por la observación de los
palestinos esto no está sorprendido O
sea no están sorprendidos los palestinos
el previo Primer Ministro naftalí benet
también hace unos años los europeos y
Los Internacionales lo estaban viendo
como
como lo más extremo que haya y cada vez
más la sociedad de israelí y los
políticos se van aún más extremos Pero
esto es una evolución bastante natural
para el estado israelí y el régimen que
en realidad siempre fue un régimen
colonialista y aún más
Cuanto más haya impunidad internacional
y Cuanto más se va al extremo la
sociedad israelí y los políticos
claro como dice sinés el extremista ven
vivir es el resultado de más de 50 años
de ocupación israelí en cisjordania y de
la normalización de este discurso de
extrema derecha que puede pasar ahora en
estos territorios ocupados si en
realidad hace 75 años o sea el proyecto
accionista y los dirigentes israelí
Siempre han tenido un discurso racista y
un discurso que normaliza la
colonización y el reemplazamiento de la
población Palestina por colonos
israelíes y esto Entonces ha normalizado
esta violencia la violencia no se va
hasta
dentro de un gobierno con uno que se ve
más moderado como Yair lápiz pues la
violencia contra los palestinos ha sido
tremenda estos dos años
ha aumentado las demoliciones de casas y
la violencia de los colonos y y todas
las políticas que están reprimiendo a
los palestinos entonces
lo que ven los palestinos es que esta
política un político o un otro no va a
cambiar de manera estructurar el régimen
ese régimen y en realidad las leyes
constitucionales israelíes que tienen
que cambiar porque este régimen es
supremacista y es racista cada día
contra los palestinos Entonces ellos ven
que cuando haya un político que está más
abiertamente
racista es solo una cara más cruda de la
realidad que los palestinos viven desde
décadas y a corto plazo Eso quiere decir
que las o sea vimos de los dentro de los
pasados años la violencia de los colonos
individuales que están apoyados y
protegidos por ejército de israelí estos
ataques están aumentando de manera
tremenda en cisjordana y esto Creo que
este nuevo gobierno que
va a
empujar y yo creo que ayudar a esta
violencia a continuar en todos estos
territorios donde los colones se sienten
como Reyes y y tienen todos los derechos
en Israel la población árabe representa
la quinta parte del zenzo israelí de 9
millones de ciudadanos Cómo fueron las
votaciones entre los árabes teniendo en
cuenta que los palestinos de los
territorios ocupados no tienen derecho a
voto si en realidad el pueblo palestino
ahora el sistema israelí ha creado
distintas jerarquías O sea hay los
palestinos que están ciudadanos de
Israel y los que están bajo ocupación
militar pero todos son palestinos que en
realidad están bajo control de Israel
controla millones de personas incluido
los de psicodán y gasa y es ellos no
tienen derecho a votar pero toda su vida
está controlada lo que sea que sea su
nacimiento su libertad o no de moverse
quién con quién casarse quien Amar o no
todas estas cosas de la vida lo controla
Israel los los palestinos dentro de
Israel que tienen la ciudadanía
israelí ellos también o sea han sufrido
de la colonización desde 75 años y se
desinteresa mucho de la política israelí
porque porque han visto que en realidad
otra vez las instituciones y las leyes
israelíes estuvieron creadas para una
supremacía judía y ellos son ciudadanos
de segunda clase no tienen los mismos
derechos y ven que las tendencias del
parlamento que sea un político de
supuestamente izquierda o de derecha No
cambia nada para ellos porque las
instituciones y las leyes y las
políticas de cualquier político de
israelí no están a favor de los derechos
de los palestinos que ellos llaman
árabes
Muchísimas gracias cine Isabel de trasec
por estar con nosotros en francés 24 y
seguimos en Irán más de un mes y medio
de las protestas masivas en las calles
por la muerte de maxa Mining luego de
ser detenida por la policía de la moral
su muerte que levantó una ola de
protesta sin precedentes lideradas por
la juventud iraníe las manifestaciones
que sí se tornaron pacíficas y fueron
pacíficas al inicio han sido brutalmente
atacadas por las fuerzas de seguridad
que han llevado también han detenciones
masivas con más de 14.000 personas
arrestadas desde la capital Teherán
nuestra corresponsal Catalina Gómez
Ángel nos Explica cómo está la situación
en la nación persa
el sábado 29 de octubre habló el jefe
máximo de la guardia Revolucionaria el
comandante José en salami y les dijo a
los jóvenes que ese era el último día de
protestas si bien no fui así ese sábado
Vimos una de las mayores movilizaciones
de las que hemos sido testigos desde que
comenzaron estas protestas Sí hemos
visto cómo se han incrementado la
represión de las fuerzas de seguridad
especialmente en las universidades
muchísimos jóvenes han denunciado como
les han negado el acceso a esos centros
educativos les han quitado su tarjeta y
básicamente han quedado por si no
expulsados han queridos ha quedado
suspendidos por el momento pero también
allí vemos movilizaciones de hombres y
especialmente mujeres que quieren romper
ese esquema en el cual tanto ellas como
ellos no pueden compartir mesa por
ejemplo en las cafeterías y siguen
comiendo todos juntos afuera en los
Campus de la Universidad donde
eventualmente vuelven y protestas pero
también hemos visto movilizaciones en
esa ceremonias en las que se conmemora
el 40 días después del fallecimiento de
las personas que ha muerto en estas
protestas esto no solamente enteran sino
en muchas provincias del país allí
También vemos represión una represión
que ha llevado a que las protestas
disminuyan no así la indignación que se
vea expresada Generalmente en las redes
sociales y en el internet a pesar de que
está bastante cortado
y terminamos en Egipto que este mes
acoge la Cumbre mundial del clima cop27
una nación que no es ajena los efectos
de la crisis climática Y es que la
fértil y productiva Región del delta del
Nilo sufre las consecuencias de esta
emergencia y de las altas temperaturas
globales que están provocando la subida
del nivel del mar esta es la historia
láminas de sal seca cubren ahora lo que
antes eran cultivos en las Riberas del
delta del río Nilo esta región en la
costa norte de Egipto es uno de los
puntos del mundo más sensibles a la
crisis climática ahora la instrucción
del mar amenaza la productividad de
estas tierras
la tierra estaba seca antes Nunca
tuvimos problemas de salinidad del suelo
ni de agua ahora los niveles de agua son
altos estamos cerca del mar la zona de
roseta está cerca del mar hemos empezado
a plantar mangos porque son más
tolerables a la sequía
los agricultores han visto como gran
parte de sus cosechas se echaban a
perder este año mientras Egipto acoge
este mes la Cumbre mundial sobre el
clima la cop 27 de Naciones Unidas para
muchos expertos climáticos los cambios
en la tierra rica y fértil del delta del
Nilo que abarcan unos 240 kilómetros
cuadrados son Realmente preocupantes de
impacto
el impacto de la subida del nivel del
mar y la intrusión del agua del mar en
el cuerpo del Delta está realmente
impactando en la productividad de la
tierra convirtiendo la tierra en un
suelo salino que realmente hace que sea
difícil de tratar para los agricultores
también la ciudad de Alejandría la
segunda más grande del país está en
riesgo la histórica metrópoli fundada
por Alejandro Magno está al borde del
Abismo por el hundimiento de su tierra y
la subida del mar
estamos intentando conseguir los fondos
necesarios ya que los proyectos para
proteger la costa son demasiado caros
las observadores de la cop 27 tienen
esperanzas de llenarlos muchos vacíos en
la pasada cumbre de Glasgow y empujar a
los países a una cooperación genuina la
supervivencia de ecosistemas como El
delta del Nilo dependen de ello
llegamos así al final de esta edición de
Expreso de oriente Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y los invito a enviar sus
comentarios a las redes sociales que
aparecen en sus pantallas y a seguir
toda nuestra información en nuestra
página web France 24.com
[Música]